Seth Doane is at Jaffa Gate in the old
city of Jerusalem where there are
growing concerns over a violent response
to this decision Seth good morning good
morning this part of the old city of
Jerusalem is now off-limits to us
government employees and their families
with some exceptions and Americans
traveling here have been encouraged to
be careful due to security concerns
recognizing Jerusalem as Israel's
capital is of course popular with the
Israeli government because it
strengthens their hold on the city but
Palestinians say it could damage the
peace process and we're already starting
to see protests in Gaza City there are
concerns about violence not only here
and across the Middle East but this also
could provide rationale for terrorist
attacks in the West as well we spoke
with one senior Palestinian official who
told us that there are plenty of
extremists already in the world and this
provides a ready-made excuse viana and
the president's announcement expected at
1:00 p.m. Eastern Time Seth Doane in
Jerusalem thank you